now let's turn to a very important issue
for all of us here at cbs this morning
as you may know
we are very committed to stopping the
stigma around mental health
medical experts say being a target of
racism can have a detrimental effect on
physical
and emotional health and may cause or
worsen depression
and anxiety that's according to the fbi
hate crimes
in the u.s reached their highest levels
in more than a decade in 2019
nearly 56 percent were motivated by race
and ethnicity
we spoke with three people about how
recent cases of harassment and
discrimination
have affected their mental health
brandon
vota is an asian-american lighting
programmer
brianna harmon is a fourth grade teacher
who was black and mexican
and alexander rosenberg is jewish and a
deputy regional director for the
anti-defamation league
when the pandemic happened i was freaked
out and
everything that's happened with that
george floyd and so many more
mentally it was draining i've personally
had a few experiences where i was told
to go back where i came from and to take
my kung flu to take the china flu with
me
over the past four years
or so we have seen nearly a tripling of
the incidents and the calls that we
received
seeing grandmothers being pushed and
shoved on the street
i saw my grandmother in those people
and that was a big awakening part for
myself because i personally uh
lost my grandmother to covet in january
i'm still going through the grief
when my boyfriend leaves and to go to
work i am always
just thinking worrying
making sure that he is safe i'm in fear
that him as an african-american man can
get pulled over
anywhere and anything can happen has it
affected me
deeply uh it has affected my family life
and it's just seeing the amount
of things that the human race
and humans in general are capable
of doing is is deeply disheartening i
think the hardest part about mental
health is feeling like you're alone in
all of it
but seeing so many people stand up has
been very
beautiful and heartwarming
the fact that all communities are
speaking out
in allyship i feel is a very welcome
change
i think the biggest thing is to speak up
not be silent and not be
either scared or don't minimalize it
share your stories we need to come as a
community together
yes we do psychiatrist dr sue varma
joins us now to discuss
sue it's good to see you i like what mr
rosenberg said that
to see what humans are capable of is
deeply disturbing i sometimes think
about that too
like how can you be so evil and be so
unkind
and i don't think it's a surprise to
anyone that you know
uh racism affects your mental health
what i want to hear from you
mental and physical health what can you
tell us about the
specifics of that about how we're
affected
yeah so gail you know discrimination
causes us to feel
excluded and rejected and i think of
this as a death by a thousand
cuts all these micro traumas layered
upon each other
causes a person in the long run chronic
stress
which if left unchecked can lead to
anxiety
depression post-traumatic stress
disorder substance abuse
and because of this chronic sense of low
self-worth
can sometimes even lead to suicide you
also talk about the model minority myth
what does that mean
yes so the model minority myth has to do
with this idea that we're supposed to
somehow be
more successful um and i look at it as
an overcompensation you know like
in a lot of cultures particularly
eastern cultures the idea is that a
person should be quiet you should fly
under the radar
you don't want to make waves and the
problem is is that just leave some
people to be a target
and we know that racism in across all
minority communities as you mentioned
not just the mental health told by the
physical toll it really wreaks havoc in
the body and puts us more at risk
for heart attacks for strokes for
obesity
for high blood pressure and get this
even premature aging we can see this on
a cellular
level gail hey sue i'm curious about the
interventions here uh what they might
potentially be
uh there was a recent study that found
that 27 of people
uh recall seeing racist content on
social media
i'm sure there's a large number of
people who also see it in their daily
life even among their own friends
how if at all should they confront it or
intervene
yes and you know the study that you're
talking about tony has to do with like
14 to 22 year olds so we're talking
about young adults whose identity has
not quite yet formed
in the young adult the their brain is
still developing executive functioning
attention and memory and they're really
um at threats for being bullied for high
suicide rates and what you want to do is
really
develop their sort of self of sense and
a sense of self and self esteem that
comes from
having pride in one's roots having pride
in your racial and ethnic identity
knowing where you came from knowing the
history and some of the accomplishments
of the great people men and women
in from your background and i think that
that can be having a great self-esteem
a buffer and be a resiliency to bullying
uh to discrimination um and to threats
but sue on the social media front is
that something people should respond to
do you think because it's
it's so prevalent out there a quarter of
the people as as tony mentioned in this
survey
say they've been exposed to it in some
way
yes you know it's so tough anthony like
how do we
we really have to be very deliberate
about our social media use and this is
something that i'm noticing about myself
is that
do we have a tendency to want to go on
what we call doom scroll is just keep on
looking for
negative information and we're looking
for certainty really that's what we're
looking for but we really need to pick
and choose
and what we need to put out there is
positive content look we cannot fight
the trolls
back with hate and really this meme of
hate is a virus is very true because
it is contagious right and it has
detrimental mental and physical health
and so when we talk about parallel
pandemics we've talked about covid we've
talked about mental health and now we're
talking about
racism as parallel pandemics and sort of
infectious sources in the community so
this really does
impact a person's mental and physics so
let's talk about head to toe
let's talk about something that's
happening in the news today it's such a
terrible day in boulder colorado i think
about the man
who said listen i almost lost my life
just going to buy some chips in a soda
grandfather talked about his people that
had gone in to get a covet shot
anybody who was in that grocery store is
experiencing trauma
those 10 families who are waking up
today without their loved ones are
experiencing trauma
what is your advice for anyone who has
gone he was experiencing trauma
right now yes so the first thing we want
to do is just get back to the basics you
know there used to be this idea of
debriefing where you needed to talk
about things we don't need to rehash
things in that moment right that will
come with time
to talk to talk therapy down the road
right now what a person needs is just
basic food comfort shelter safety we
call them their five things
a sense of self-efficacy that i can do
things
a sense of safety that you know i'm not
gonna get re-traumatized a sense of
hope that better days lie ahead a sense
of calm
through meditation through relaxation to
through talk therapy
and a sense of connectedness we know
that social support as somebody who used
to work with the 911 mental health
program i work with victims of
911 and survivors and we know that
social support across the board
really helps decrease some of this
trauma and it is very very painful
there's going to be a lot of grieving
and i'm hoping that we can get together
you know one of the things that we
missed in the in covit is being able to
hug one another
the role of physical touch the role to
have be able to mourn together
to to touch and and an oxytocin is a
hormone not secreted
when we're feeling stressed when we're
feeling anxious and touch
can bring that down yeah human touch so
important thank you sue varma always
good to have you here
if you or someone you know is seeking
mental health resources you can call the
national alliance on mental illness
helpline
that number is 1-800-950-6264
that number again is 1-800-950
or in a crisis text nami spelled n-a-m-i
to 741-741